من امام السفينه الحربيه الامريكيه التي
وصلت للتو الى ميناء جده الاسلامي وتحمل
على متنها 222 راكبا من جنسيات متعدده
قادمه من بورسودان هذه السفينه تعتبر
السفينه الثانيه للامريكيه
الحربيه وهي من ضمن عمليات الاجراء التي
تنفذها فرقاطات وسفن وتجاريه وعسكريه
اجنبيه اليوم نتحدث عن عمليات الاجراء
التي نفذتها الفرقاطات العسكريه الاجنبيه
او كذلك السفن التجاريه الاجنبيه هي
تتجاوز 15 سفينه طبعا السفينه العسكريه
الامريكيه هي دخلت في مؤخرا ضمن عمليات
الاجلاء لعل سبقتها الفرقاطه الهنديه
وكذلك الصينيه وكذلك السفن الفرنسيه او
السفينه واحده فرنسيه التي قامت باجراء
بعثه الامم المتحده وكذلك الهنديه وايضا
سفن تجاريه من دول متعدده ولكن السفن
العسكريه الامريكيه هي كانت اخر السفن
التي دخلت في ضمن عمليات الاجلاء وتحديدا
التي كانت
مغادره من ميناء بورت سودان الى وجهتها من
جده الاسلامي وهذه هي السفينه الثانيه
فقبل يومين كانت تحمل
305 اشخاص من سته عشره جنسيه والسفاره
الامريكيه لم تفصح عن عدد الجنسيات التي
تحملها هذه السفينه ما نشاهده هم وجود فقط
جنود على متن وظهر هذه السفينه بعضهم يحمل
السلاح وبعضهم ايضا ينتظر نزول الرعايه
وفي الطابق السفلي من السفينه ايضا نشاهد
عدد من الطاقم الفني الذي هو بانتظار
الاذن الاخير لنزول الرام وهو الرام
المتصل
السفينه وكذلك الذي سوف يكون بين السفينه
ورصيف من جده الاسلامي عموما نحن ما زلنا
في اطار اخذ او اذن الاخير من قبل الامن
السعودي حتى يسمح بنزول هؤلاء الرايه ولكن
هناك اجراءات ايضا داخل السفينه في حال
توقفها في حاله ايضا يتم التاكد من عدم
خلل امنيه او كذلك فنيد للسفينه قبل نزول
هذا الرام او هذا الجسر طبعا ايضا لا ننسى
اذا لم تفصح ايضا السفاره الامريكيه ما
اذا كان على متن هذه السفينه حالات طارئه
او حالات صحيه او كذلك اصابات مثلما كان
في السفينه الاولى فكانت هناك ثلاث عصابات
ولكن حتى الان لم يتبين لنا ما اذا كانت
هذه السفينه تحمل مصابين او ايضا مرضى او
ايضا ركاب لديهم حاله صحيه
ولو وجد هذا الامر فان هناك تواجد للاسعاف
الخاص بميناء جده الاسلامي وايضا هناك
الطاقم الطبي يتواجدون على الرصيف الخاص
والذي نقف فيه في ميناء جده الاسلامي
المرحله التي سوف تلي نزول هؤلاء الركاب
سوف يتجهون مباشره الى الحافلات ونشاهد
ايضا هنا حافلتين والاخريات في الخارج وهي
من ضمن التجهيزات التي وفرتها الخارجيه
السعوديه والتي سوف تقل هؤلاء الرعايه
وعددهم 222 من جنسيات مختلفه الى مقر
اقامتهم حتى يتم انهاء اجراءاتهم والتنسيق
مع قنصلياتهم وسفاراتهم لمغادرتهم جده الى
بلدانهم لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات